L'alcool fait faire des conneries.
Enfin, pas à tout le monde, heureusement,
mais il est clair qu'il modifie
notre comportement et notre jugement.
Mais il n'y a pas que l'alcool ou les drogues
qui peuvent modifier nos actions ou nos décisions,
il y a aussi tout simplement les hormones qui sont
naturellement présentes dans nos organismes.
Aujourd'hui dans "Crétin de Cerveau", on se fait
un petit tour d'horizon de ces substances chimiques
qui viennent perturber la façon
dont on prend nos décisions.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Parmi les substances chimiques qui affectent
de manière visible notre comportement,
l'alcool est certainement le plus répandu
et ça fait un moment, puisque les plus anciennes
traces de boissons fermentées dont on dispose
remontent à il y a environ 10 000 ans.
Et même certains chimpanzés
en consommeraient en milieu naturel.
Pour commencer il faut savoir que la consommation et
les effets de l'alcool ont été très étudiés par les chercheurs.
Ça peut se comprendre vu les problèmes
que pose l'alcool sur le plan de l'addiction,
mais aussi des accidents de la route,
des comportements violents ou risqués,
comme par exemple des relations sexuelles non protégées.
Il est difficile ici de résumer toute
la littérature scientifique sur le sujet
mais bon, je vais essayer d'en donner
quelques résultats principaux.
Tout d'abord, les effets que l'on attribue
traditionnellement à l'alcool
ressortent effectivement dans les études en laboratoire.
C'est prouvé "scientifiquement", l'alcool joue par exemple
un rôle sur notre capacité à contrôler nos mouvements
mais il affecte aussi notre mémoire,
notre capacité d'attention et notre humeur.
Sur le plan social, l'alcool a un effet désinhibant,
il favorise l'excitation sexuelle,
mais aussi les comportements violents.
Bon, il est probable qu'en disant ça
je ne vous apprenne pas grand chose.
Ce qu'il y a d'intéressant surtout avec ces études,
c'est de pouvoir mettre des chiffres sur ces phénomènes,
mais il y a quand même quelques effets un peu
moins intuitifs que les chercheurs ont découvert.
En 2003, une étude a mesuré l'impact de l'alcool
sur le jugement que l'on porte sur le physique des autres.
Des sujets, ayant bu de l'alcool ou pas, regardaient
des photos de personnes qu'ils ne connaissaient pas
et ils devaient leur attribuer une note d'attractivité.
Et ceux qui avaient bu mettaient systématiquement
de meilleures notes que les autres,
mais uniquement aux personnes de sexe opposé.
Alors je suis sûr que sur la base
de votre expérience proche ou personnelle,
vous ne doutez pas des effets de l'alcool
sur notre organisme, mais dans les années 70 et 80,
des chercheurs se sont demandés s'il n'y avait pas
une part psychologique de l'effet de l'alcool
et si l'on ne pouvait pas, tout simplement, reproduire
certains de ces effets en donnant un placebo.
Pour tester cette idée et bien séparer
les effets physiques des effets placebos,
ils ont imaginé un protocole particulier.
Chaque fois qu'on veut faire une étude,
il faut diviser les participants en 4 groupes :
un groupe à qui l'on dit qu'il reçoit
de l'alcool et qui en reçoit effectivement,
généralement un mélange de vodka et de tonic.
Un groupe à qui l'on fait croire qu'il en reçoit
mais qui reçoit un placebo, c'est-à-dire juste du tonic.
Un groupe à qui l'on dit qu'il ne reçoit que du tonic
et c'est effectivement ce qu'on lui donne.
Et enfin, un groupe anti-placebo
à qui on fait croire qu'il va recevoir juste du tonic,
mais dans lequel on ajoute de la vodka en douce.
Alors, faire ce genre d'expérience n'est pas simple et,
rassurez-vous, tout est bien encadré et contrôlé.
Mais pour que la supercherie de l'effet placebo
fonctionne, il faut toute une mise en scène.
Les expériences se passent dans une pièce
qui reproduit le décor d'un bar.
Un serveur prépare les boissons devant les sujets
avec de vraies bouteilles de tonic et de vodka,
pour les mettre dans l'ambiance.
Evidemment, le contenu des bouteilles est truqué
selon les besoins de l'expérience.
Et en plus de ça, les chercheurs ont recours
à tout un tas de subterfuges,
notamment pour les groupes à qui on doit mentir.
Donc par exemple, pour le groupe à qui on fait croire
qu'il reçoit de l'alcool alors qu'il n'en reçoit pas,
on est obligé de vaporiser de l'alcool sur le verre
pour reproduire l'odeur caractéristique.
Grâce à ce type de protocole, les chercheurs ont bien pu séparer
ce qui était l'effet physique, pharmacologique de l'alcool,
de tout ce qui relève de l'effet placebo.
Et bien, figurez-vous que l'effet placebo est énorme.
Ce qu'on constate, c'est que pour les effets vraiment physiques
comme le contrôle des muscles, l'attention
ou bien la capacité à traiter de l'information,
le rôle de l'alcool est bien réel.
Mais pour tous les comportements
que l'on peut qualifier de sociaux
comme l'excitation sexuelle ou l'agressivité,
qu'on vous donne de l'alcool ou bien qu'on vous donne
un placebo en vous faisant croire que c'est l'alcool,
le résultat est le même.
Alors, il y a plusieurs études de ce genre,
mais je vous en détaille une.
On a soumis des sujets à une expérience
selon le protocole dont j'ai parlé, donc avec 4 groupes
et ensuite, on leur a donné accès à des images
sous forme de diapositives.
Chaque personne voyait 24 images
qui étaient de 4 types différents :
des images neutres,
des images érotiques,
des images violentes,
et enfin des images à la fois érotiques et violentes.
Les participants contrôlaient librement
quand passer d'une diapositive à l'autre
et donc, il pouvaient regarder chaque image
autant qu'ils le voulaient.
On a mesuré le temps moyen qu'ils passaient
sur chaque type d'image et voici les résultats :
si on compare tous ceux qui ont reçu de l'alcool
et tous ceux qui n'en ont pas reçu,
indépendamment de ce qu'on leur a dit,
on ne voit pas de grosses différences dans les temps passés.
On voit qu'ils préfèrent les images à caractère érotique, ok,
mais le fait d'avoir bu de l'alcool n'a pas eu d'influence.
Par contre, si on compare ceux à qui on a dit
qu'ils allaient recevoir de l'alcool
et ceux à qui on a dit qu'ils allaient juste recevoir du tonic,
on constate une différence nette.
Le fait de croire, à tort ou à raison, qu'ils avaient bu de l'alcool,
leur faisait passer plus de temps
sur les images érotiques et/ou violentes.
Le temps passé à regarder ces images
n'est donc pas influencé par la prise d'alcool,
mais par la croyance qu'on en a bu.
C'est un effet placebo.
L'interprétation de ce résultat par les chercheurs,
c'est que pour des comportements qui sont considérés
comme socialement moins acceptables,
comme l'attirance pour la violence ou pour le sexe,
le fait de croire qu'on a bu de l'alcool nous donne
une sorte d'excuse et donc nous désinhibe,
indépendamment de l'effet réel de l'alcool.
Mais voyons maintenant une autre manifestation
assez amusante de l'effet placebo.
♪ [Générique] ♪
En 2012, une équipe française
a fait une expérience dans un bar
où ils ont demandé à des gens de se noter
eux-même sur une échelle de 1 à 7,
pour dire à quel point ils se trouvaient
attractifs, brillants, originaux et drôles.
Ensuite, ils ont corrélé les notes que les gens
s'attribuaient avec leur alcoolémie.
Et devinez quoi : plus on a bu, plus on se met
à soi-même de meilleures notes.
Mais pour bien séparer l'effet réel de l'effet placebo,
ils ont du faire une expérience un peu mieux contrôlée.
Ils ont réuni 94 participants et ils ont utilisé
toujours le même type de protocole
où on fait 4 groupes en fonction de ce qu'on
leur annonce et de ce qu'on leur donne vraiment.
Après avoir consommé leur boisson, les participants
devaient créer un petit speech sur un thème publicitaire imposé,
et venir le jouer sur une scène où ils étaient filmés.
A la fin, on leur repassait le film et on leur demandait
de noter leur propre prestation.
Voici les notes moyennes que se sont attribués
les gens dans les 4 groupes.
On voit que les meilleures notes sont celles des
participants qui pensaient avoir reçu de l'alcool
et ce, indépendamment du fait
qu'ils en aient effectivement bu ou pas.
Alors à ce stade, il y a deux hypothèses :
soit le fait de croire qu'ils ont reçu
de l'alcool a faussé leur jugement,
soit leur prestation était effectivement,
objectivement meilleure,
c'est-à-dire, le fait qu'on a reçu
de l'alcool nous rend meilleur orateur.
Mais bon, en fait ce n'est pas ça.
Pour le savoir, les chercheurs ont fait aussi noter les prestations
par un panel de personnes indépendantes et à jeun.
Et là, il n'y avait pas de différence entre les 4 groupes.
C'est que l'effet placebo joue bien
sur notre propre auto-évaluation
et pas sur la qualité de ce qu'on produit.
Une des questions les plus importantes qu'on se pose
au sujet de l'alcool et des plus difficiles aussi,
concerne ses liens avec les comportements risqués.
Est-ce que l’alcool nous fait prendre plus de risques ?
La question n'est pas simple parce que ce n'est pas
évident d'interpréter les données existantes.
Prenons l'exemple classique des accidents de la route.
On sait qu'en état d'ébriété on conduit moins bien
et donc qu'on va avoir plus d'accidents.
Mais en plus de ça, est-ce qu'il y aurait
un effet supplémentaire de l'alcool
qui nous ferait prendre plus de risques inconsidérés.
La difficulté pour trancher scientifiquement la question,
c'est qu'il n'est évidemment
pas simple de réaliser des expériences
pour tester notre propension à prendre
plus de risques sous l'influence de l'alcool.
Mais il y a au moins un domaine dans lequel
on a pu le faire, c'est celui des risques économiques.
Je vous ai déjà parlé dans un épisode précédent
de la série "Crétin de Cerveau"
de ce qu'on appelle l'aversion aux risques.
C'est le fait que, si je vous donne le choix entre toucher 100€
ou toucher 300€ mais à seulement une chance sur deux,
une majorité de gens préféreront la première option,
celle qui n'est pas risquée,
même si en moyenne, la deuxième est plus intéressante.
La plupart des humains ont une aversion aux risques.
La question que se sont posé des chercheurs, c'est
de savoir si l'alcool diminuait notre aversion aux risques
et donc nous ferait courir plus de risques,
du moins sur un problème économique comme celui-ci.
Et bien, la réponse est non.
Sur les expériences qu'ils ont menées, la prise d'alcool
ne diminue pas significativement l'aversion aux risques
et même chez les femmes, elle a un peu tendance
à l'augmenter, c'est-à-dire à les rendre plus prudentes.
Cette question est intéressante dans le contexte
notamment des jeux d'argent.
On sait qu'à une table de casino ou de poker,
on ne boit pas que du sirop.
Est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un lien entre la consommation
d'alcool et la prise de risques au jeu ?
Et bien d'après cette étude, pas de manière claire.
En revanche, on connait une substance chimique dont
on sait qu'elle a un impact dans ce genre de situation,
c'est la dopamine.
♪ [Générique] ♪
La dopamine est un neurotransmetteur,
c'est-à-dire une petite molécule
qui est libérée au niveau des synapses qui sont
les points de communication entre les neurones.
On sait que la dopamine joue notamment
un rôle dans la motivation
et dans la manière dont le cerveau
se récompense lui-même.
On sait aussi que la maladie de Parkinson qui se
caractérise par des problèmes de contrôle des mouvements
s'accompagne de la perte de certains neurones
qui normalement secrètent de la dopamine.
Donc, un des traitements pour soigner
les symptômes de la maladie de Parkinson
c'est justement de donner de la dopamine.
Enfin, pas directement de la dopamine parce qu'elle
ne pourrait pas franchir la barrière hémato-encéphalique,
celle qui permet de passer du sang au cerveau.
Du coup on donne, soit des molécules
qui lui ressemblent, on parle d'agonistes
et qui sont capables d'activer les mêmes récepteurs,
tout en passant la barrière,
soit de la L-Dopa qui est un précurseur de la dopamine,
c'est-à-dire une molécule que notre cerveau
saura ensuite transformer en dopamine.
Ces traitements de la maladie de Parkinson
sont très répandus,
mais avec certaines molécules et sur certains patients,
on a constaté des effets secondaires
très spectaculaires et franchement handicapants.
Le traitement provoque chez eux
une forte addiction au jeu et parfois au sexe.
Ça reste heureusement des cas assez rares,
mais des chercheurs se sont demandés si la dopamine
pouvait avoir une influence sur la prise de risques
au-delà des ces patients, dans la population générale.
Pour ça, ils ont pris des sujets et ils leur ont fait faire
des expériences dans deux conditions,
une première où ils recevaient un placebo
et une deuxième fois où ils recevaient de la L-Dopa.
Dans ces expériences, ils étaient soumis
à une série de décisions sous forme de jeu
où à chaque fois ils avaient le choix entre deux options.
Une option certaine où on gagnait
une quantité fixe d'argent
et une option risquée où le hasard intervenait.
Ils ont constaté que dans l'expérience
où ils avaient reçu de la L-Dopa,
les sujets prenaient plus souvent un choix risqué
que dans l'expérience où ils avaient reçu un placebo
et plus on augmente la dose de L-Dopa,
plus l'effet est prononcé.
Même si, pour être honnête,
l'effet n'est pas non plus énorme.
Voyons maintenant une autre substance pour laquelle
l'effet est cette fois indéniable, la testostérone.
La testostérone est une hormone sexuelle
qui est impliquée dans le développement
des organes sexuels mâles chez la plupart des vertébrés.
Elle est secrétée par les testicules, même
si les ovaires des femelles en produisent aussi.
Dans la nature, des taux de testostérone plus élevés que
la moyenne sont notamment retrouvés chez les mâles dominants
et chez les hommes, la testostérone a des liens
démontrés avec le comportement sexuel
ou même simplement dans le couple.
Par exemple, pour une même tranche d'age,
les hommes avec des niveaux de testostérone
élevés sont moins souvent mariés,
plus souvent divorcés et trompent plus souvent leur femme.
Mais comme pour l'alcool ou la dopamine,
des chercheurs ont voulu évaluer son impact
sur les décisions économiques,
notamment quand il y a
un élément d'interaction sociale.
Pour ça, ils ont utilisé ce qu'on appelle le jeu de l'ultimatum.
Le principe est le suivant, on a deux joueurs
qui vont occuper un rôle différent,
on met une certaine somme au milieu de la table, disons 40€.
Le premier joueur doit proposer un partage
de cette somme entre les deux,
par exemple, il propose 25€ pour lui et 15€ pour l'autre
et le deuxième joueur doit décider s'il accepte le deal ou pas.
S'il accepte, l'argent est effectivement
partagé de cette manière,
mais s'il refuse, l'argent disparaît et personne ne gagne rien.
Dans tous les cas, on ne fait qu'un tour,
après ça le jeu se termine
et il n'y a pas de négociation possible,
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça le jeu de l'ultimatum.
Analysons rationnellement ce jeu.
Le deuxième joueur a le choix entre
prendre l'argent qu'on lui propose
ou refuser le deal, auquel cas il ne touche rien.
L'attitude rationnelle pour lui est donc,
normalement, d'accepter le deal quel qu'il soit,
même si l'autre joueur ne propose pas grand-chose.
Mais sachant cela, le premier joueur, lui, a intérêt
à proposer un partage vraiment inéquitable
et à proposer le minimum possible au second joueur
puisque celui-ci est sensé accepter tout.
Ça c'est le raisonnement rationnel, mais dans la réalité
ça ne se passe pas du tout comme ça.
Ceux qui sont dans la position du premier joueur
vont assez fréquemment proposer
un partage relativement équitable
même si rationnellement, ils ne seraient pas obligés.
Quand à ceux qui sont dans la position du second joueur,
ils vont parfois refuser une offre qui leur parait injuste
quitte à se sacrifier parce que, du coup,
ils préfèrent ne rien toucher
que de toucher le résultat d'un partage injuste.
Un chercheur de l'université de Harvard, Terence
Burnham, a fait une expérience en utilisant ce jeu.
Il a recruté des hommes et les a fait jouer,
mais uniquement dans la position du deuxième joueur,
celui qui décide d'accepter ou de refuser la proposition.
Et le premier joueur était en fait un complice
qui proposait systématiquement de partager les 40$
en 35$ pour lui et 5$ pour le sujet de l'expérience.
Burnham a classé les sujets suivant qu'ils acceptaient
ou rejetaient cette offre plutôt inéquitable
et il a mesuré ensuite leur taux de testostérone
et là, grosse différence.
Les hommes qui avaient refusé l'offre avaient
un niveau de testostérone 50% plus élevé que les autres.
Là, quantitativement, le résultat est très net,
mais il faut quand même être
un peu prudent dans l'interprétation.
On démontre qu'il y a une corrélation
entre le niveau de testostérone
et le fait, disons, d'être agressif
dans les échanges économiques,
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y ait un lien de cause à effet.
On pourrait imaginer qu'il y ait un troisième facteur,
des prédispositions génétiques par exemple
qui influence à la fois le niveau de testostérone
et le comportement économique.
D'ailleurs, une étude ultérieure a montré
que sur des femmes ménopausées,
le fait de leur administrer de la testostérone
était sans effet sur ce type de décision,
donc ce n'est pas forcement juste en vous gavant de
testostérone que vous allez devenir le loup de Wall Street.
Mais passons maintenant à une autre hormone
qui a beaucoup fait parler d'elle ces dernières années,
l'ocytocine.
L'ocytocine est une hormone qui est impliquée
dans les comportements maternels,
notamment au cours de l'accouchement
et pendant l'allaitement
et on lui attribue aussi un rôle
dans les comportements d'empathie.
En 2005, un groupe de chercheurs a publié une étude
visant à étudier les effets de l'ocytocine
sur certains comportements sociaux.
Ils ont eux aussi utilisé un jeu économique,
mais différent, le jeu de l'investisseur.
Dans ce jeu, on prend 2 joueurs.
Le premier sera l'investisseur
et le second est appelé le dépositaire.
Au début du jeu, l'investisseur reçoit
une somme d'argent, par exemple 10€
et il a le choix d'en conserver
une partie et d'investir l'autre.
Mettons qu'il garde 4€ et qu'il investisse 6€,
la somme investie est triplée par la banque
et remise au second joueur, le dépositaire.
Ici, il reçoit par exemple 18€.
Le dépositaire doit décider alors du partage
de cet argent entre les 2 joueurs,
par exemple, il peut décider de garder 10€ pour lui
et de redonner 8€ à l'investisseur.
L’intérêt de ce jeu, c'est qu'il permet de mesurer
une notion de confiance de la part du premier joueur.
Faisons à nouveau une analyse
purement rationnelle de la situation.
Le second joueur, d'un point de vue strictement égoïste,
a intérêt à tout garder pour lui
et à ne pas rendre l'argent
et donc le premier joueur, l'investisseur,
sachant cela a intérêt à ne rien lui confier du tout.
Sauf qu'en pratique, le premier joueur a quand même
tendance à investir une partie de la somme
en faisant confiance au second joueur
pour qu'il lui en rende une part suffisante.
En utilisant ce jeu de l'investisseur,
l'équipe de Kosfeld et ses collaborateurs
a mesuré à quel point la confiance, c'est-à-dire
les choix effectués par le premier joueur,
étaient influencés par le fait qu'on ait pris
de l'ocytocine ou bien un placebo
et là, ils ont vu un effet assez spectaculaire.
L'investisseur ayant reçu de l'ocytocine
par voie nasale avant le jeu
a beaucoup plus tendance à faire confiance
que celui qui a reçu un placebo.
En particulier, il y a une proportion très significative
de ceux qui ont pris de l'ocytocine
qui choisissent de courir le risque maximum
et d'investir l'intégralité de la somme
pour la confier au dépositaire.
A ce stade, on pourrait se dire que l'ocytocine
brouille simplement les raisonnements
comme l'alcool ou bien fait courir
plus de risques comme la dopamine.
Mais pour écarter cette hypothèse,
les chercheurs ont fait une autre expérience
où cette fois le deuxième joueur, le dépositaire,
était remplacé par un ordinateur,
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y avait plus de relation humaine.
Et là, l'effet positif de l'ocytocine sur la confiance
qu'accorde le premier joueur disparaît.
Leur interprétation, c'est donc que l'ocytocine ne brouille
pas les comportements et n'augmente pas la prise de risques,
mais elle augmente la notion de confiance
quand il y a une interaction sociale.
Les résultats de cette expérience ont été assez médiatisés,
notamment par un des auteurs de l'étude, Paul Zak,
qui en a fait un peu son fond de commerce
et a commencé à écrire des livres et donner des conférences pour expliquer qu'il avait découvert l'hormone de l'amour
la molécule de la morale, etc..., à l'américaine, quoi...
Mais comme toujours, il faut relativiser.
Les études qui ont été faites ultérieurement ont montré
que le rôle de l'ocytocine n'était peut-être pas si nets
et même qu'il pouvait être un peu ambigu.
Par exemple, l'ocytocine favoriserait
le sentiment d'appartenance à un groupe
et donc augmenterait l'agressivité envers ceux
qui ne font pas partie du groupe.
Bref, l'ocytocine a certainement un rôle sur notre
comportement, après tout c'est une hormone naturelle,
mais méfiez-vous des gros titres qui lui attribuent
des vertus un peu trop simplistes.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo.
Comme d'habitude, abonnez-vous,
appuyez sur la cloche, likez, tout ça...
Si vous voulez des news de la chaîne, vous pouvez
me suivre sur Twitter ou sur Facebook
et ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir sur Tipeee.
Merci, à bientôt.